honestly you know what you know why I
think this really works there's
something about the initial breaking the
story in the concept but whatever the
mood board was for this movie with all
those different tones and all that was
just it was creatively inspired I mean
it's really an inspired reinvention
Robert Downey jr. couldn't have said it
better so this is going to be my
slightly more in-depth Spider Man video
because the embargoes up we could talk a
little bit more about details so I'll
explain a little bit about how they
combine the Ultimate Universe with some
of the more classic spider-man things to
create something that you've never seen
before but it's still very much a
classic spider-man film there's a new
brand of that spider-man ticket giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
so you've probably seen a lot of
people's reviews there haven't been that
many people that I've seen have been
down on the film it's currently the
highest rated spider-man film on Rotten
Tomatoes if you care about Rotten
Tomatoes at all I know there's all kinds
of controversy associated with that
website but like I said in a lot of my
other videos the whole thing with this
movie is that Kevin Feige wanted to do
something that they had never done
before so in order to do that they went
to the ultimates universe so this is a
very Peter Parker driven spider-man
story but if you read the ultimate
spider-man comics you know that was all
paving the way for Miles Morales to come
so I'll address him later in the video
because they've already started
releasing information about what's
happening with the future film in the
way they wrote the movie it actually
sets up a much bigger Spider Man in the
MCU universe than I ever thought because
Sony has their spider-verse that they're
trying to spin-off I had a lot of ideas
about big spider-man villains they could
do but they set so much of that up
during homecoming that you're like wow
Marvel is going to get to do all the
cool stuff so even though they're doing
Ultimates universe they still find ways
of doing a lot of classic spider-man
stuff from the 6-1-6 universe so if
you've ever read the original Civil War
comic and you know the history of
spider-man and Iron Man's relationship
obviously their relationship and the
movie ends on a much better note just
getting you really excited for the next
movie he gets to do all this crazy stuff
with the heroes that he admires then the
next week
has to go back and sit through class
which is it's the most boring thing ever
for him and you really feel Tom Hollands
journey as he comes into his own and
finds his own identity as Peter Parker
because he's this little kid that gets
to be a hero for a little while and he
gets really drunk on the idea like
spider-man is so much more exciting than
Peter Parker maybe I can be spider-man
all the time but just like comic books
spider-man with Iron Man he sort of gets
iron band up with the iron spider suit
then through the course of civil war
decides that Tony has the wrong idea I'm
going to retake my identity back and
puts the old costume back on
spider-man's Ark during homecoming is a
lot like that where he gets really
caught up in all this Avengers stuff but
then by the end of the movie finds that
being the friendly neighborhood
spider-man is really what he wants to do
now in Tony couldn't be happier for him
Robert Downey jr. is always a big
box-office draw so when people saw them
using him to market the movie they
started freaking out oh my god is this
going to be Iron Man homecoming I
thought it was supposed to be a
spider-man movie so all of the marketing
material is very misleading there is
very little Iron Man in the movie he's
just there to bridge the gap between
civil war at the beginning of the movie
just like okay we're dropping you off
you have to go back to school now and at
the end of the movie like okay kid time
for even bigger cooler stuff in the next
movie which is going to be infinity war
so one of the biggest surprises is that
the trailers really weren't that
spoilery for the movie they cut things
differently there are a lot of shots in
the trailers that didn't make it into
the final cut of the film happy hogan
was a great Iron Man surrogate during
the film always more Jon Favreau in
these movies I don't know if he'll come
back for the next fighter man Home
Coming movie it sounds like he won't
just because the Avenger that's going to
be with Peter Parker is going to be a
different character it won't be Iron Man
again because that picks up after the
fourth Avengers film so there's going to
be all kinds of crazy shifting with the
Avengers team I'm expecting a couple
people to die off I've already done a
video about that I'll link that at the
end of this but if you've heard things
about how Avengers characters are going
away in Spider Man is on the rise and
he's going to be a much bigger
centralized figure in phase four the
movie does a good job of setting that up
because it teases some really big
spider-man villains that we'll see
either in the next
or in the third movie without really
doing spoilers both of the post-credits
scenes tease really big things that are
coming up and I think one of them is
mostly dealing with stuff for the third
spider-man homecoming film because it's
so big the other one is open to
interpretation it's mostly used for
comedy like the guardians of the galaxy
post-credit scenes tease really big
things but some of them are just meant
to be kind of funny we can talk more
specifically about it when the movie
comes out and people have a chance to
see it but if you actually have seen the
post-credits scenes please don't post
spoilers in the comments even though
this is my spoiler review I feel like
there are a couple of things that we
probably shouldn't talk about till after
the film comes out but the big
spider-man heroics were an easy slam
dunk like you want the really big
spider-man stuff you want really good
character work and I feel like Marvel
solved their bill and problem even
though I knew they were going to solve
it because of Cate Blanchett she's the
villain that I'm most excited for inside
the MCU
but Michael Keaton's character just
absolutely kills it so he is a villain
so he does go a bit crazy during the
film but the way he goes crazy is
actually very believable these rich guys
like Tony Stark get to do whatever they
want walk all over people why shouldn't
I do the same thing why shouldn't I get
my piece of the pie the way they tie him
to the spider-man character totally work
for me
so of course you have all of these big
action set pieces where people are
wearing their masks it's like something
right off the comic book page but then
you have all these hero villain
interactions where they're not wearing
their mess and I feel like that's where
a lot of the Marvel villains even the
spider-man villains have fallen down in
the past so Michael Keaton kills it as
Adrian Toomes and as the vulture just
like Tom Holland did a great job with
his Peter Parker and with his spider-man
so as for the supporting cast there's
been a lot that's been made there's
already people they're having meltdowns
about some big character reveals
lizallen is a great love interest for
Peter Parker for most of the film they
do a great job of setting up Zendaya's
character as sort of this wild card it's
going to be much bigger in the later
films so the weird thing about her
character that people are having
meltdowns about is is that they're
giving her some really big twist from
the 6-1-6 universe even though she isn't
the character that you think that she's
playing but
there was a bit of a twist that I felt
like was okay but a lot of people will
have a problem with and I can totally
understand where you're mixing and
matching names but I almost don't want
to talk about it too much because it's
another one of those post credit level
reveals it's not a post credit scene
it's something that happens through the
natural course of the movie but she's
meant to be an ultimate universe spin on
a very big spider-man love interest from
the 6-1-6 universe so she is an original
characters they're not going to change
her name in the second movie she'll
still be Michelle in spider-man
homecoming 2 or whatever that movie ends
up being called they do a great job of
fitting her in and sort of this oddball
bookworm who is interested in Peter
Parker without being a damsel in
distress they do a good job of setting
up a potential future relationship with
those characters without making a
beeline for that during the film like
he's all about lizallen for most of the
film it's not like he's going to pivot
on a dime and all of a sudden he's going
to start going out with Michelle's
character cannot say enough about Aunt
May's the movie does a really good job
of allowing her to participate by being
a relatively neutral figure in Peters
life because she doesn't know about his
secret so she just gets to be this big
sister character who helps take care of
him while he's trying to take care of
her they have a great relationship but
there is a big seismic shift late in the
film that makes me really excited for
what the future of their relationship is
going to be in the next film so do not
be afraid that Peter Parker is going to
continue to be in high school in the
next film and even in the third film
because they're speeding through big
spider-man reveals and plot super fast
so they're going to get to all the
really big stuff while he's still in
high school so any big spider-man story
that you've ever heard about Tom
Hollands been talking about Clone Saga I
don't think they're going to do that but
they're getting to all the really big
characters the big villains by the end
of the trilogy the only real thing I
didn't talk about in my non-spoiler
review was the score so obviously they
work in a lot of spider-man themes from
the classic TV show in a really funny
way but Michael Giacchino did an awesome
job
it feels very organic like a spider-man
film should like you listen to Iron
Man's theme songs you get more ac/dc
it's a little more rock n roll the Danny
Elfman spider-man theme from Tobey
Maguire's era is still one of my
favorite tracks
of all time I feel like that was one of
the most perfect movie scores and I feel
like at the end of the day this film is
at least as good as spider-man 2 even if
a lot of people are still hung up on
that bill because it was so amazing it
still held up as one of the greatest
superhero films of all time not just
good spider-man films but best superhero
films so if you're a big fan of The
Ultimates universe it's all in there
they've already confirmed that Miles
Morales exists in the universe but I
don't think that we're going to see him
anytime soon maybe after this trilogy
with Tom Holland is done there's an
animated ultimate spider-man movie
that's coming out with Miles Morales
that's where he'll be for the time being
but the film does a great job of being
true to the spider-man character without
all the best things being supplanted by
Iron Man MCU thing so yes it's a very
Marvel Avengers driven universe but the
film is still very true to the
spider-man comics with a few minor
twists from The Ultimates universe
favorite moments for the film are
definitely like the last 10 minutes they
end with such a big bang that you're
like oh my god I can't wait for the next
spider-man so I can't wait for infinity
war which you do get a chance to see the
film let me know what you thought about
it in the comments it's going to be
rolling out around the world next week
so some of you might actually be seeing
it as I'm posting this video right now
but what's going to happen next is is
I'll be doing a Doctor Who video
there'll be some new Rick and Morty in
Game of Thrones I'll say congratulations
to Andrew white you're the latest
giveaway winner please private message
me on the back end of my channel so I
can get your contact details you can
click here to learn about the future of
the spider-man character in phase four
what's going on with infinity war and
you can click here to learn all about
the infinity war trailer and my best
predictions thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome
see you guys tonight